cuidad mujer poderosa feliz con la piel
arrugada de tanta sabiduría sabiduría
con mucho verde verde de bosque nativo
lleno de mil colores hijo de la central
ritual del teñido ríos cascadas aves
cantando aire fresco lluvia fecunda y
cielo
eso es uy atrás
witran es el telar que me ha regalado
conocimiento que me ha regalado
sabiduría que guarda entre sus obras de
lana suave mi pasión mi alegría hebras
que me tejen y me conectan con mi ser
si estoy enojada entrenar se aprieta se
endurece pero también se fortalece
cuando estoy feliz los colores salen
vivos salen alegres y brillan
cuando estoy triste el telar también lo
está entonces en mi abraza me consuela y
eso también se transmite
una vez una tejedora me dijo mis colores
son muy tristes
bueno entonces esto nos emociona ahora
le dije el telar nunca miente
soy anita villamil y soy witral desde
muy niña
vi a mi madre tejer unas inmensas
frazadas inmensa en ese tiempo ahora me
río bailan tan inmensas hay más inmensos
ella siempre tejía a diario pero ella
siempre estaba como enojada como muy
seria me costaba mucho entender su
actitud en ese entonces pero después con
los años logré comprender lo seria que
ella de ella está el frente a su tejido
para poder transmitir eso también a
nosotros tomarlo con seriedad y respeto
bueno nosotros todos chicos mis hermanos
cuatro hermanos seis ocho diez años le
pedíamos pan mientras ella tejía
y ella decía cuando termine de tejer les
voy a dar pan que hacíamos nosotros
tomamos sus lanas tomamos un hierro de
wes y nos poníamos a tejer junto a ella
para que terminaran luege nos pudieron
dar pan
mi madre me contó que cuando chica ella
vio su madre tejer pero no aprendió con
los años ella se fue a santiago estuvo
viendo allá mucho tiempo pero por temas
de salud tuvo que regresar nuevamente al
sur
y en ese entonces ella recordó el telar
mientras estaba sola
ella hermoso y telar y su primer tejido
fue
una manta adivinen para quién
para mi padre una manta para mi padre
desde entonces ella se dedicó a tejer
frazadas principalmente piezas de abrigo
tanto para la familia y también para
tejidos que le mandaban a hacer
era tanto él
la exigencia que tenían nuestros
nuestros padres con respecto a
conectarnos con este tipo de tejido
recuerdo que cuando tenía como 10 años
llegando del colegio mi madre siempre me
mandaba a cuidar los animales pero no me
mandaba con las manos vacías me mandaba
con un rollo de lana
y me decía cuando llegues a la casa
tienes que haberlo terminado
y la verdad es que yo sufría porque no
podía
no podía jugar no voy a jugar con mis
amigos no voy a jugar con mis vecinos y
en ese entonces apareció mi primo el
primo juanito que tiene la misma edad
que tengo yo entonces anita juguemos
pero juguemos y yo no podía ya eso lo
corrió la flamante idea de ir a la casa
de su madre robarle un ovillo de lana
colocarlos me uso para que yo pudiera
jugar con él la verdad es que mi mamá
nunca lo supo quizás ahora después de
esto se entera no lo sé probablemente sí
con el tiempo entre estudios y tejidos
me contactaron para hacer clases me
pidieron enseñar este arte inicialmente
al principio me dio mucho miedo me dio
miedo porque sentía que había gente
mayor dentro de estos grupos de mujeres
pero realmente dije no por tengo que
hacer que este arte tengo que hacer que
este conocimiento no se pierda y al
mismo tiempo también necesitaba vivir
necesitaba generar ingreso económico
para mi familia y para mí y tomé la
decisión y me dediqué a hacer clases he
recorrido mucho y la verdad es que he
tenido la suerte de ir a muchos lados
enseñando mi arte enseñando mis tejidos
y cuando estoy tejiendo cuando estoy
haciendo clases la verdad es que me
olvido que estoy haciendo clases agarro
mi telar agarraste la lumbre y me ponga
dijera hasta que uno de mis alumnos me
dice profe ahora sigo yo estela es mío
me olvido me concentro demasiado
he recorrido varios países estaban
alemania estaba en italia estaban
estados unidos mostrando siempre mi arte
mostrando mis tejidos y la verdad es que
eso me hace ser una mujer orgullosa de
ser mapuche y orgullosa de ser tejedores
mi abuela
la culpable de que yo sea tejedora ya no
vive físicamente
cuando yo nací
ella ya había emprendido su viaje a
encontrar a encontrarse con sus
ancestros
tampoco tengo fotografías de ella en
verdad no la conozco
pero ella habita en mí
sé que lo que hoy soy gracias a ese
conocimiento que ella me heredó siento
que cada hebra de lana que es enlazada
en mi telar está guiada por su mano
sabia que da vida a este arte que luego
fortalece con mi madre en la actualidad
solamente hago tejidos a pedidos a
personas muy especiales no me dedico a
tejer a diario pero si me dedico a hacer
talleres
los veo de buena manera
como una obligación también creo que
este conocimiento y conocimiento y esta
herencia que dejaron nuestros
antepasados es necesario difundirla es
necesario señal
hace un tiempo atrás conocí a un artista
conexión artista
chileno-estadounidense
me contacto con una idea muy loca que él
tenía
se contactó con muchísimas artesanas de
acá de chile de la novena región
principalmente para trabajar en un
proyecto que tenía mente él buscaba
alguien tan loco como él yo creo y entre
esa búsqueda me encontró
aceptado mucho desafío en la vida y eso
fue uno desafíos que de alguna manera
era más que un desafío era poder mostrar
mi arte de una manera distinta
y una forma de decir que nuestro tejido
de decir que nuestro arte no es pasado
ahí está la prueba que ven ustedes
ven cierto como una técnica en central
se conecta con la tecnología
en estos tejidos pudimos colocar códigos
qr fueron los primeros textiles
codificados hechos con una técnica en
central imagínense lo orgulloso que debe
estar mi abuela
el telar no es pasado
estelar el futuro y lo seguirá siendo
mi witral me enseña me protege me
acompaña en mi vida no pasa un día en
que no tenga un telar frente a mí
me ha hecho viajar por mundos divinos
y también por este mundo terrenal cuando
necesito energía
estelares mi vida
así un par de años atrás
estaba postulando un proyecto de
investigación de iconografía mapuche en
el museo del indio americano en
washington presenté la postulación
pienso que fue como en octubre
estaba a la espera de ese resultado
y me llegó noviembre la fecha de todos
los santos
desde muy niña mi madre siempre nos
llevó al cementerio a dejarle flores a
nuestros abuelos eran esperábamos a
todos los santos para poder llegar a
visitar a nuestro abuelo cementerio
y este año cuando firman el cementerio
junto a mi familia me pasó la verdad es
que algo increíble
estaba junto a mi familia preparando las
flores adornando la sepultura de mi
abuela andábamos como 15 15 familiares
fue en ese entonces cuando nos retiramos
del cementerio vamos saliendo con la
puerta por esas cosas de la vida miré
hacia atrás
cuando veo que se coronó flor yo así
como no lo voy a crear me devuelvo voy a
plantar la flor de nuevo
empiezo a escarbar la tierra y me
encuentro con un tubo un tubo que mi
abuela me había heredado en ese entonces
no lo podía creer porque en verdad no
era algo que yo buscaba yo lo que
buscaba era siempre tener a mi abuela y
adornarla y tenerle siempre con ella lo
mejor posible su sepultura
mujer poderosas guerreras vieja con la
piel arrugada de tanta sabiduría feliz
veo a mi abuela feliz porque ella me
veis joven porque sabe que voy a recibir
su conocimiento y que lo voy a
transmitir
ella sabe que estando en mi poder su
conocimiento no se va a perder me voy a
encargar transmitir
ella siempre estará en mi poderosa
guerrera y sabía cómo mi telar que
siempre se mantiene de pie
soy anita para ella milk y soy witral
[Aplausos]
[Música]